it's a ton of fun to see our favorite
Disney characters come alive in human
form but some Disney characters seem
impossible to cosplay we found 10 of the
toughest characters to recreate and
we're about to reveal the fans who still
managed to pull off watch until the end
to find out which Disney villain was the
most challenging of them all
Ursula sometimes those poor unfortunate
souls try to cosplay one of the darkest
Disney villains of all time
Ursula unfortunately they don't always
succeed but do you know who didn't fail
at being Ursula josè Davalos check out
Jose's award-winning cosplay is not easy
playing a giant tentacled sea witch
especially when she's as purple as a
grape josé's and makeup looks absolutely
stunning we can't believe how much this
guy looks like Ursula and Ursula
wouldn't be complete without her cronies
flotsam and jetsam those two eels are
attached to Jose's dress no wonder he
won Best cosplay at the 2017 San Diego
Comic Con he definitely deserved it too
fede and tuka ok so plain to see which
is pretty difficult but you know what's
even harder playing a goddess who is
also an island yep we're talking about
defeat II and touka from Disney's Moana
remember they are the same goddess touka
was just the scary monster who had her
heart stolen son child cosplay and amber
Skye's cosplay decided to take on the
challenge of portraying the same
character in two very different forms
and they did an incredible job
Tiffany is gorgeous and looks just like
the animated original and Takei looks so
legit it's scary these two showed up at
the d23 Expo back in 2017 this is one
epic cosplay Celia May Monsters Inc gave
us some of the most lovable Disney
characters ever still it's a huge
challenge to accurately cosplay these
characters but cosplays organic OHS was
up for the challenge
she dressed up as Celia Mae who is known
for being Mike's girlfriend in the
franchise she's a one-eyed purple
monster with snakes in her hair this
cosplayer picks the perfect outfit and
she put purple stuff snakes in her wig
[Music]
how did she deal with having more eyes
than Celia well she discovered one eye
with her hair this cosplay is just so
creative she definitely captures the
essence of what makes Celia who she is
who knew being a monster could be so
pretty
scar things got complicated when you try
to dress up as an animal scar is the
villain from The Lion King he is one of
the most recognizable characters ever
cosplaying animals like scar usually
means wearing big costumes which can be
extremely challenging a youtuber who
goes by the name of cor adorable decided
to change it up she recruited scar
entirely from makeup the transformation
is incredible she finishes it off by
making her hair look like a mane and
adding ears we can't get over how
detailed this makeup job is she
definitely looks more like a lion than a
human once her transformation is
complete
Lumiere okay so far we've seen sea
witches monsters and lions these
characters all have one thing in common
they're very much alive but wait how do
you cosplay an object instead of a
creature just ask Jews Skellington he
brought Lumiere from Beauty and the
Beast to life and we don't mean the way
The Enchantress did this cosplay is
absolutely stunning we love the gold
detail over the long black coat and the
wax head is incredible seriously how did
he do that the makeup looks just like
Lumiere's face we are so impressed maybe
he'll do Cogsworth next time we
definitely love to see that dory
even if Dory is your favorite character
you might not think to cosplay her why
well she's a fish and fish don't have
arms and legs but you can still dress up
as dory if you're super creative and
like to think outside the box
our mermaid style dress could definitely
pass as fins so that's what Caroline
Knight decided to wear to portray her
favorite Disney character the blue dress
has black and yellow accents it looks
just like the pattern of dory scales she
added gloves that are the same pattern
as stories front fins this costume may
look simple but it is just so creative
King candy King candy was the villain
from wreck-it Ralph
he was goofy on the outside but ruthless
on the inside King candy is not easy to
cosplay he's supposed to look animated
because he's from a vintage arcade game
but Paul strike definitely pulls off the
right paw
his outfit is totally over-exaggerated
just like the original and even though
he's human he looks like he belongs in a
game we think it's those rosy cheeks
that give him that animated look fans
crave but we have one question how did
he get that tiny crown to stay on his
head since there's no obvious answer
we'll chalk it up to magic inside out
this next cosplay might make you feel a
little emotional these friends decided
to cosplay together as Riley's emotions
from inside out and some things are just
better together all of the emotions are
there joy disgust anger sadness and fear
and we cannot believe how perfect they
look from the body paint to the costumes
these cosplay buddies pay attention to
every detail joy is even holding the
core memory that gets lost in the movie
who would have thought that dressing up
his feelings would look so good Hades
he's the smooth-talking god of the
underworld Hades is the villain and
Disney's Hercules his blue skin and
exaggerated features make him pretty
difficult to cosplay but an artist who
calls himself your pain decided to bring
Hades to life and we can't believe our
eyes his transformation is top-notch the
contouring of his makeup makes him look
like he jumped off the drawing board the
blue hair is exactly right and he has
the creepy grin that we expects from
Hades we loved the photo is surrounded
by blue flames he looks totally wicked
but in a good way yzma
yzma might be the creepiest looking
disney villain of all time the old lady
from Emperor's New Groove always looked
away less than human but she thought she
was gorgeous Jay Stryker Khan is known
for his amazing cosplays and spectacular
makeup skills
he's cosplay Ozma and the resemblance is
uncanny the outfit is exactly the same
including the feather on her head and
the makeup is really impressive too he
managed to make himself look like a
real-life cartoon character we can't
believe how great this cosplay is he
even shows off yzma x' cringy
personality this is just so good tell us
about your favorite cosplay in the
comments and that's a wrap hit that
subscribe button so you never miss
another video from the things and make
sure to give these cosplay artists a big
thumbs up thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]